en este hospital los preparativos no
paran instalan generadores de energía y
calderas para asegurar que no falte el
agua mientras que dure el impacto del
huracán aida ya tenemos mucho
combustible que hemos traído tenemos
generadores portátiles que podemos mover
a diferentes regiones dependiendo cuáles
son nuestras necesidades
mientras tanto en la ciudad de hama las
personas cierran sus casas y aseguran
con diferentes materiales sus puertas y
ventanas
estoy poniendo tablas blindamos dos
edificios de enfrente llevo unos días
cubriendo muchos edificios preparándonos
y cruzando los dedos
otros corren hacia las gasolineras para
surtirse de combustible
ahora mismo sólo estoy buscando un poco
de gasolina tengo a mi familia de
regreso en casa instalamos el generador
y solo estamos obteniendo combustible la
mayor cantidad que podamos
decidimos partir sí porque estuvimos
aquí en katrina y no queremos estar
durante el desastre así que no vamos a
correr el riesgo nos vamos
días antes los aeropuertos se llenaron
con largas filas de personas que
decidieron dejar la zona antes de una
posible restricción de los vuelos aéreos
los ciudadanos esperan que los
preparativos puedan contrarrestar la
fuerza de un huracán que se prevee que
sea extremadamente peligroso y cuyas
lluvias ya tocan luisiana